leading up to this as you know your
personal reputation is sort of a
conflict with your movie how are you
feeling today about about that you know
you know look um you look at the film
you know last night we had screened the
film and I was able to bring my cast and
number my crew onto the stage and just
to hear them speak about the film you
know the take it and making movies hard
it's been like four hundred plus people
put their time and energy into the film
and uh and that's been my focus yeah you
know some of my calves have never been
tipped before right it's my third time
eunos would be it to be there and
introduce them to Cameron Bailey and
hear him talk about the film it's been
such an experience not just for me for
for so many others so it's uh you know
and then to see the reception to the
film in the midst is I feel very blessed
I feel very blessed that the country of
Canada and internationally people are
responding to because when you have
sundance that's all you got yeah you
know and people talked about Sundance
and I'm very proud of that but it's a
domestic audience a lot of independent
filmmakers the test just on the film the
merit of the film was here and it seems
as though it's a passing those tests
you're passionate you've been passionate
about things in your life are you do you
understand when people may have a hard
time going to see the movie because of
your reputation because of the story
blows of look you understand that like
do you sort of empathize with that at
all or listen it's like a it's hard to
stick with the interesting thing is that
you know I've addressed this yeah of
times and not assured future forms are
i'll address it more um but i do feel
like you know this trip these next few
days is about the film it's about the
other people that put their blood sweat
and tears in it and i'd have to honor
them in their work in there were
Catholic and
in their blood sweat tears not and I
gotta um uses a moment to celebrate them
you know a lot of them work for very
very very little very good so this is a
reward and when you do put so much of
yourself into something what do you
possibly do next huh something that
makes you want to put the same amount of
yourself will you put this much will you
do it all again everything if I have to
you know I I didn't say to myself I have
to write direct produces star I just
said it has to be done and it just so
happened that that was the only way it's
different times I realized I was the one
and had to push it so I just felt
blessed it we're here we have a movie
yeah you know then it actually happened
I still pinch myself then we can swing
whole sweats there's no longer yours
it's the world's now that's exactly
right yeah i stake not yours anymore
thank you thank you so much appreciated